[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to the brief authoritative
history of night city
this chapter is devoted to so-called
styles
deeply linked with the history of the
world and a very important aspect of
life in the city
you can find them everywhere in cars
clothes guns implants
they are your war paint as one of our
sponsors says
it matters not if you're dead as long as
you're doing it in style
the moves on this girl swish swoosh
slicing them up like sashimi
four visual styles are evident in the
night city of 2077
each with its own history status and
features
neon hair illuminated tattoos and chrome
function comes second looks are what
matter
[Music]
i'm your leader
stanley here with you and we got another
day ahead of us in this
city of dreams
the fourth corporate war broke out and
entropism was born
vast and deep crises forced people to
find ways to survive by any means
getting the job done no matter how was
the primary goal
the look who cares i
love this town love it like you might
love a mother who popped you out on the
steps of an orphanage once
and now stops you to ask if you got a
smoke for her
[ __ ] them [ __ ] this job [ __ ] this city
deadly elegance without ostentation
corporate militaristic fashion mostly
seen in the wealthier parts of town
substance over style that's the motto
[Music]
[Applause]
celebrities brain dance stars business
magnates
heirs to corporate fortunes and
corporate executives
they abandoned the cold deadly elegance
of neo-militarism
and returned to the roots of kitsch but
gave it a fresh
new look oh [ __ ] these hands
sometimes seems like i just brushed
something in spark supply
thank you for your attention we wish you
a very pleasant stay in our marvelous
metropolis
good luck and goodbye
legends know where you'll find most of
them
the graveyard luckily matters not where
you're from
matters not where you start
matters here is the walk you walk
[Music]
you